hey youtube this is um this is i'm going
to show you what happens when you open
up
microsoft office powerpoint 2007 for the
first time after you install camtasia
studio 6.
so i'm going to open powerpoint 2007 for
the first time
and there's a splash screen and here is
the actual powerpoint and it takes a
second to load because it says welcome
to the camtasia studio powerpoint add-in
we notice that this is your first time
running powerpoint with the add-on so
we've opened a presentation to get you
started
so it's going to show you how to record
a powerpoint and use that feature i'm
going to uncheck the show tip again box
and hit ok
so now they have
five slides i can actually open up this
open up the actual powerpoint and show
it to you full screen if i wanted to but
basically it's giving you this whole
lowdown on how there's a window in here
on how to actually record powerpoints
directly
inside of camtasia which is really nice
feature um if you've actually bought the
software or used my video on how to get
the software
um you can actually use this quite a bit
so um i hope you like this tutorial or
not quite tutorial but uh just showing
you what happens and thanks for watching
peace
also i've got to show you the uh how to
actually use it in powerpoint if you
just open up powerpoint real quick
um
um i'll use this
window and you just click the add-ins
tab and right here you have a record
button you can direct record directly
from your webcam you can record uh you
can show the camera preview
uh it says on this
on windows vista the camera preview will
be recorded by default if it appears in
the recording area okay
and there i am you can see me in the
camera preview it's pretty good quality
actually because it's so compressed
so um
so it does work pretty well um if we go
to
can we can set the recording options
which there's a whole ton of options
always with camtasia studio
so um if you like this tutorial go ahead
and subscribe um i'll do a lot more
videos also go ahead and send me a
personal message uh if you need another
video to be filmed so uh thanks for
watching guys peace